the reveal of the four house common
rooms in the new hogwarts legacy trailer
had to be one of the most epic moments
it's one that i know fans have been so
excited to see regardless of which house
you're in we have all been waiting to
see what is our common room going to
look like are they going to get it right
and while i have to say across the board
i think they did a phenomenal job in
today's video we're gonna rank the four
common rooms some tough decisions coming
up guys it's all good i'm already
prepared for the dislikes because i know
i'm gonna be taking haters from all
sides on this one and full disclosure
here as most of you who follow the
channel know i'm a gryffindor so keep
that in mind maybe i'm gonna grade
gryffindor's a little bit more harshly i
don't know we'll have to wait and see
and i know some of the folks at
avalanche watch my videos from time to
time so if you guys see this just know i
truly am excited for all four of these i
really do think you did a phenomenal job
but again tough decisions we gotta make
them and with that let's get into it now
watch as i flash these up on screen very
quickly and you're gonna notice
something particularly striking and it's
the color palette you don't even have to
see them on screen for very long because
your brain is just instantly able to
detect the color and thus detect the
correct house even without actually
looking at all of the finer details that
they put in here and there are quite a
few which we're going to talk about but
just the color palette alone they did a
phenomenal job with with gryffindor's
you have kind of the burgundy red with
hufflepuff it's this very earthy brown
and some yellows ravenclaw lots of blue
a little bit of brown and bronze even
some silver in there and then slytherin
you just have the dark you can tell it's
in the dungeon but then you also get
this green hue over everything so i love
the fact that even without taking into
account all the other little details you
can just instantly look at these and
know exactly which common room you're
looking at all right so to start our
tier list here let's begin with
gryffindor this one's interesting
because it is the one that we have most
of a visual reference for given the fact
that we have seen these in eight movies
now we also get very vivid descriptions
of this one in the books because that's
where harry spends so much of his time
while he's at hogwarts so as for
gryffindor we know their mascot is the
lion the colors are red and gold so i
don't know how avalanche felt about
approaching this one it's kind of a
blessing and a curse when you have all
these details do you make it exactly
like it is in the books and movies do
you do completely your own thing or do
you settle somewhere in between and i
think that is mostly what they have done
here right away you're gonna notice
these big comfortable chairs lots of red
in terms of the rug and then the
tapestries on the wall the house banners
then you have the stones a nice globe
right here in the middle and then over
on the left side here just below the
portraits you can see the armor of a
knight here and so as a gryffindor
myself i mean i like this it feels like
home i don't know that there's anything
here that really wows me to be quite
honest with you and again i think that's
just because we have seen this common
room so many times at this point this
one i do feel like from what we've seen
so far they played it a little bit safe
here which again it's fine it's the most
familiar common room you already have so
much to work with so at the end of the
day there's not anything here that i'm
just like oh my goodness i don't like
this at all but again as a gryffindor
myself i'll say it feels like home as
for the ranking itself and again i
reserve the right to change these as we
go along some might move up some might
move down but for right now i'm gonna
put the gryffindors at a solid b tier
all right now let's move to hufflepuff
now this one was obviously a big deal
because this is the common room that we
have probably seen the least across all
of the other common rooms harry never
visits this common room in the books we
only get very minimal descriptions for
it now i've heard i've been corrected
online because in another video i said
this is the first time we've ever seen
the interior of it that's actually not
true it's appeared in some other video
games and some other artwork online as
well but regardless it still remains
true that this is the one we have seen
the least and i will say even though i'm
not a hufflepuff just instantly i say
yes i mean as soon as i see this i say
yes absolutely this screams hufflepuff
to me everything about this i love the
fact that they went with the round
doorways i mean yeah maybe it's
borrowing from lord of the rings a
little bit there we've got that whole
hobbit hole vibe going on but i am
totally here for it all the plants
around along with this light-colored
wood just give this a very sort of
earthy feel it's very well lit i also
love the little shelves over here the
floating shelves i guess you would call
these over on the left side they all
have little plants on them now keep in
mind we we do know that hufflepuff is
very close to the hogwarts kitchens as
for hufflepuff the mascot of course is
the badger the colors are yellow and
black all the hufflepuffs i've ever met
are also just generally gregarious
generally outgoing and this totally
feels like a common room to me where you
would want to go and hang out all sorts
of chill vibes here and i'm absolutely
loving this one honestly like i'm kind
of hovering between s tier and a tier
you know what we may bump it down later
but i'm gonna go with ester for now i
think they absolutely knocked it out of
the park with hufflepuff again maybe
it's that newness factor that's
influencing me a little bit here because
the fact that we have seen this one so
little but i gotta say i am totally
loving what they've done with the
hufflepuff common room here and can't
wait to explore more of it all right for
ravenclaw we have the eagle as their
mascot which hogwarts legacy got correct
by the way they did not use a raven they
also got the colors correct blue and
bronze for the house banners on
ravenclaw so as soon as you take a look
at this one it feels very regal to me i
love the patterns on the floor here you
guys can probably let me know exactly
what this is in the comments here but it
looks like some sort of astrology
pattern here and then over on the left
you also have the telescope keep in mind
they are in ravenclaw tower so like
gryffindor's ravenclaws also have a
tower then you have the little sculpture
here on the right and then the
bookshelves of course ravenclaws
bookshelves have to be featured
prominently and i love the little arch
of the doorway right here and look at
this room the first thing other than the
color that strikes me about this room is
the balance just look how carefully
balanced this room is and so i think
they did a really good job with the
ravenclaw common room but i want to see
more of this one i'm kind of hovering
between b and a tier honestly because i
part of me wants to give it an a i think
if i see more it could probably be an a
but for now i'm going to put it as a b
and slightly above the gryffindor common
room here and finally we move to the
slytherin common room now this one we
haven't seen as much as gryffindor but
we have seen it quite a bit in the
movies and it's also described in detail
in the books as well and we all know the
slytherin house mascot of course is a
serpent with the colors being green and
silver and just instantly looking at it
you totally get a feel that we are
absolutely in the dungeons here it's
very dark except for this light kind of
shining through in the middle and also
the seating is very spread out in this
one i don't know maybe that's to let
slytherins go and sort of plot and plan
on their own i'm not sure exactly and
then over on the top right here we can
see the skull of an animal possibly a
dragon there i hesitate to even guess
because every time i guess something and
get it wrong you guys freak out in the
comments so my apologies if it's not a
dragon whatever it is some sort of
creature there i love the vibe that that
gives off though and this one almost
feels a little bit like ravenclaw to me
and i want to see just a little bit more
like if we could see over here on the
right side it looks like this opens back
up and then obviously if we could go
straight ahead we'd be able to see a lot
more in that direction as well but i
definitely think they nailed the feel
for it honestly you know what i think
i'm gonna do here when it comes to the
tier list i think i'm gonna put
slytherin at b slightly above gryffindor
and then i'm gonna go ahead and move
ravenclaw to a so let's take a look here
and see how i feel about this now we've
got hufflepuff as the s tier i i think
i'll stand by that i agree the
hufflepuff by far is the one that i just
get the best feel for off this very
limited shot that we've seen which again
it's a very limited glimpse of the
common room here gryffindor solid
ravenclaw really like what i see i just
want to see even more of it i'm going to
bump it up slightly though because i do
have it a notch above slytherin and i
was kind of hesitating between a tier in
the first place anyway so we're going to
go ahead and put it in the a tier here
slytherin and gryffindor i'll keep at
the beach here again very solid on both
of these but i do think that gryffindor
and slytherin were probably the hardest
to do mainly because the fact that you
already have so much to work with you
don't want to disappoint fans who have
already got something in mind for
exactly what they know these common
rooms look like but then you also want
to put your own spin on it as well now i
know you guys will not hesitate to let
me know how wrong i am on all of these
but instead of doing that how about we
do this how about we change up the
formula here a bit guys why don't you
let me know one of your favorite
features in each of the common rooms and
once you're done with that you can check
out the video on the right side of your
screen where we explore seven of the big
questions that i still have about
hogwarts legacy as always thank you all
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again soon